a new CBS News battleground tracker poll
puts the Democrats in a better position
than Republicans to gain control of the
House of Representatives in November's
midterm elections but many contests are
still considered toss-ups analyzing poll
numbers is the specialty of CBS News
director of elections and surveys
Anthony salvano he's out with a new book
called where did you get this number
a pollsters guide to making sense of the
world it's published by Simon & Schuster
a division of CBS Anthony good morning
good morning thanks for having me
what do you make of this poll well
Democrats are in a stronger position
than Republicans and they've gotten a
little bit stronger over the summer our
estimate now has them at 222 seats
versus the 218 that would be needed for
control but there's a margin of error on
that and there are plausible very
plausible scenarios in which the
Democrats gained seats but fall short of
control and the Republicans hang on to
it you know I already see back-and-forth
on the internet about what this means
and people saying we're winning and
we're winning and one of the things I
wanted to get across in the book is hold
on a second okay let's go pass the horse
race and let's look at what people are
thinking and feeling and it's August
that's the dynamic that's the
interesting part yeah I feel like your
book should also be in the in the
grocery store because it's a grain of
salt it's like take these numbers but
here's the important grain of salt you
always need tell us about a constituency
though that you're looking at in the
next few months that'll be really
important well the women's vote really
stands out here in that there are some
women and some moderate women and also
some Republican women who say feel a
little bit conflicted they don't like
how the ham president handles himself
personally they do like how he's
managing the government and so they've
drifted a little bit away from saying
that they'll vote for a Republican
candidate and I think that's part of
that that's one of the key
constituencies to watch trickly is the
worried turnout that they won't turn out
or that they'll vote for the other team
I don't see them crossing over to vote
for Democrats right now it's turnout but
it's also turnout on the Democratic side
there's many who say they haven't voted
in midterms before who tell us they'll
turn out now we'll see we were all
together on election night 2016 which
was a long night for everybody
and real nail-biter people said well
that proved that the polls were wrong
but were they no yes thank you to
everybody no well first of all you know
this is again looking past the horse
race and also looking past the national
polls which actually turned out to be
very accurate which what you wanted to
do was go a step beyond because she won
the popular vote yeah yeah and all the
signs were there
look Republicans at the same time a
little bit like now Republicans were
talking to us in the polls but saying
they weren't sure if they were going to
back Trump were we really shocked that
they came home they work and serve it is
Democrats were telling us they weren't
enthusiastic well we should have
understood there then but they might not
show up and in fact they didn't so while
it did surprise a lot of people if you
saw the whole picture and I like to
think that our viewers got a lot of that
story maybe you weren't as surprised
people underestimated the margin of
error that's for sure last week we spent
a lot of time talking about Millennials
and how though they are very opinionated
and outspoken they're not voting what's
going to change if anything this
election cycle yeah I think that's a
great question you know we ask people
why don't you vote when we then they say
that they're not going to they're not
always interested they don't always see
how politics connects to their lives and
part of what even I talk about in the
book is pollsters wrestled with this too
how do we measure that when somebody
says that they're not interested what
would make them change and become
interested so we try to get at that when
you see and everybody should know what's
in your numbers likely voters when I
come on and talk about likely voters
that's our best estimate based on all
these questions we ask how long have you
lived in a place do you feel a sense of
community are you tied to it does that
make you want to get involved
all of those things are things that
we're trying to get at - I love how you
gave a tick-tock of election night again
- because I've been wanting to sort of
revisit what happened that whole night
because it was so chaotic how everything
changed and you and you point out here
that that I reported just after 1:00
a.m. that John Podesta was heading to
the stage to tell the crowd that things
were too close to call and I said and
then I said he's going there to say it's
too close to call and then Gail said is
it too close to call or not wanting to
accept reality yes I think that was
really the moment we all realized
it's probably done for her yeah you guys
had some good lines because I'd
forgotten about yeah yeah yeah no I went
back and you know I was watching the
tapes and I was listening from over
there and I think you learned something
about how you read the polls that night
and the data that was coming in what did
you learn about ways to do it better in
the future yeah
turnout is one of the big things and
that's why I want to emphasize that
story for everybody that you know this
year it's not predetermined and polls
are not predictions when people are
telling you they're uncertain believe
them
yeah you know that wasn't earning on for
and also not turning out and we're not
turning out for a road go out and vote
right right and there's still an
argument to be had there's still an
argument to be had out there for this
for a couple months
yeah we could talk I could talk forever
for this you have anyway thank you so
much love the book where did you get
this number goes on sale tomorrow